bonjour à toutes et à tous bonjour j mee
bonjour federica et bonjour jacques
schwarz bart
bonjour bonjour immense honneur pour
nous de vous recevoir ce matin honneur
et plaisir
nous apprécions votre musique nous nous
le disons ici vous êtes un saxophoniste
dans le style gwo ka jazz et vous êtes
venu donc interprétée ici en martinique
ce sera ce soir sur la scène de
tropiques atrium soneca la deux donc
c'est un album un deuxième opus d'une
collection pour ainsi dire qui est
peut-être en tout cas vous nous le dit
recchi qui est donc sorti récemment le
premier sonné cas là était sorti en 2005
et à son sujet à ce sujet de ce premier
album
ce n'est qu'à la vous dites que le
respect générés par ce projet eh bien il
vous a valu de devenir professeur
associé à la berklee school of music
aux etats unis c'est ça ce n'est pas
rien d'ailleurs une école dont vous êtes
vous-même diplômés tout à fait ça y est
vous y êtes professeur grâce à son nez
cas là c'est ce que vous nous expliquer
oui oui en fait je n'aurais complètement
qu' il y avait en fait une quinzaine de
professeurs de berkeley qui étaient des
fans du projet et qui qui débattait de
me faire venir depuis déjà des années
enfin je te toutes ces conversations je
n'en avais aucune idée et finalement
lorsqu'ils m'ont contacté pour faire une
première clinique dessèche je dirais
c'est là que j'ai vu que j'avais un
support étonnant là sur la base donc de
ce disque et vous préciser aussi que
alors vous atelier à écrire depuis déjà
plusieurs années la suite du projet
voilà alors qu'est-ce qui a évolué
qu'est ce qu'il y a
changer entre soneca là et ce n'est qu'à
la deux alors je tiens d'abord à dire
que son égal à 2 n'a pas encore été
enregistré donc il n'ya pas de disque et
qui a été enregistré encore moins qu'ils
soient sortis
donc c'est un projet encore inédit donc
les je suis content de pouvoir vous
présenter en avant-première si vous
voulez oui c'est ça va primer le
deuxième concert de ce n'est qu'à la
deux et je mon principe c'est que je je
je tourne un moment un an parfois deux
ans avec un projet avant de
l'enregistrer d'accord pour qu'il ait
vécu vous le rodez en quelque sorte
voulu donner du vécu oui tout à fait
parce qu'en fait ce que vous entendez
généralement sur les disques sur des
projets qui n'ont pas vécu donc les vous
allez écouter ce projet en live et vous
dit à chaque fois mais c'est bizarre je
sais tellement mieux en live et c'est
parce qu'en fait vous entendez quelque
chose qui à l'époque qui n'a pas qui n'a
pas évolué donc voilà donc demain soir
enfin ce soir
oui ce sera le deuxième alors alors vous
avez joué on a en guadeloupe on a on l'a
interprété en guadeloupe la première
fois à terre de blues à marie galante
plus exactement il faut faire faut
respecter tout à fait
la nationalité marie-galantaise donc sur
l'île de marie galante voile présentée
est donc ce qui il ya trois éléments qui
ont singulièrement évolué depuis la
première fois c'est déjà que toutes les
mélodies sont joué au saxophone et
chanter à la fois par la voix de mal
qu'à 4 rien
le deuxième élément c'est que et il y a
beaucoup de sonorités électriques aux
claviers ggg des effets souvent sur mon
sur mon saxophone et sur le projet final
y aura pas mal de basse électrique aussi
on va on va y venir à sète
cette sonorité particulière que vous
donnez justement et l'oeil le dernier
élément c'est que relaie d'avoir deux
cas dans la section se dirait rythme
j'ai un cas et une batterie parce que
depuis la création de ce n'est qu'à la
initialement dont deux en 2005
beaucoup de batteurs ont commencé à
transférer le langage du cac à la
batterie et le travail de sonny troupé
de d'un os de la main et de tous ceux
qui qui qui qui ont suivi depuis
effectivement nous ne nous permette de
d'avoir ce langage mais mais interprétés
à la batterie donc c'est encore ce lot
de sonorités alors justement c'est
vraiment une touche particulière avoue
brother jack comme on vous surnomme
affectueusement aux etats-unis 1 y
compris les musiciens avec qui vous
jouez
alors c'est cette touche jacques schwarz
bart c'est effectivement un style
classique de jazz qui est mêlé donc avec
des du rythme traditionnel guadeloupéen
revisité et puis donc ses sonorités
effectivement technologique quoi c'est
ce que c'est ça cette touche un peu
particulier
oui je sais c'est l'une des aspects il
ya d'autres aspects c'est qu'ils sont
par exemple la façon dont je construis
mes lignes de basse vous entendez
souvent dans des projets qui impliquent
le gros cas et des instruments que la
base suit le le le
le tambour répète exactement les accents
du tombeau alors que je j'ai toujours
des lignes de base qui sont en
contrepoint du tambour pour compléter
une sorte de fresque rythmique qui kills
qui donne je pense 1 1
un sentiment polyrythmique et aussi de
réponse est de 2,2 de questions et de
réponses il voulait d'appel de mons a
non seulement du côté mélodique mais du
côté rythmique
il ya aussi une volonté d'aller puiser
des harmonies dans
[Musique]
un univers un peu impressionniste plutôt
que dans le jazz je dirais traditionnel
traditionnels voilà donc effectivement
une musique vous faut dire quand même
très élaborés et donc ceux qui la
connaissent et l'apprécient déjà
pourront donc l'écouter ce soir et ceux
qui ne connaissent pas encore vont le
découvrir dans ce concert de ce soir à
tropiques atrium jacques schwarz bart
vous êtes souvent qualifié de deux
saxophonistes humaniste alors on l'a pas
dit peu de gens peut-être le ne savent
pas toujours vous vous avez fait des
études de sciences politiques vous êtes
diplômé de sciences po paris
vous avez même été à un moment attaché
parlementaire au sénat
voilà bon bien sûr vous êtes le fils de
andré et simone schwarz bart d écrivain
mondialement connu le guadeloupéen
donc voilà je disais saxophoniste
humaniste et citoyen du monde puisque
vous êtes partagés entre l'europe les
états unis
vous vous vivez voilà vous fait la
navette entre europe antilles et états
unis ça vous va ça cette taxe au phone
east humaniste et citoyen du monde
écoute et oui je trouve d'ailleurs que
compte tenu de ce qu'on sait de
l'univers le le ce qu'on appelle le
monde et est en fait un petit grain de
sable dont donc
je trouve que passer des états unis à
l'europe ou aux antilles ccc déjà trop
peu donc je n'ai je l'aurais voulu
pouvoir faire mon métier dans 3000 ans
où on pourra commencer à aa a joué sur
vénus est d'accord bon ça viendra
peut-être pourquoi pas un concert de
jacques schwarz bart sur la lune ou sur
vénus allez on va on va terminer donc
vous êtes né en guadeloupe quand même on
le rappelle puisque j'ai dit que oui oui
voilà tafer wasabi voilà des nouvelles
de votre mère simone schwarz bart qu'on
a vu très récemment dans un très beau
documentaire consacré à son mari est
donc votre père andré schwarz bart
oui dans le temps j'ai fait la moue oui
d'ailleurs vous avez fait la musique
tout à fait ben écoute et elle va très
très bien pour une femme de son âge très
bien vous avez en guadeloupe et à côté
de vous un c'est un patriote un jimmy
damas oui même beaucoup moins bon
saxophone que monsieur chasse barque
malheureusement pour moi dernière
question jacques schwarz bart le citoyen
que vous êtes et qui vivait donc souvent
aux états unis quel regard qu'ils
portent sur ce pays et son président
enfin la politique actuellement bon
voilà avec même les dernières nouvelles
à non ça c'est franchement c'est de voir
une horreur totale
la seule chose qui peut être le rattrape
sait qu'il n'a pas le commencer de
nouvelles guerres
contrairement aux derniers présidents
républicains qui a perdu au suffrage
universel mais a gagné grâce au système
du collège électoral vous parlez de
george bush junior boys and i exactement
équipiers qui a envahi l'irak sur un
mensonge
mais oui c'est ça l'amérique l'amérique
de 7,1 c'est un désastre
c'était des as pure et simple c'est
cette renouveau à la fois du nazisme du
racisme pur de ces mouvements
suprémacistes blancs qui se sentent
envie gorée et donc qu'ils se sentent
autorisés a à dire et à agir de façon de
plus en plus outre hager et est souvent
criminels également voir meutrières mais
le bon côté de tout cela c'est que ça
sacré d'un autre côté une réaction de la
part d'une grande une majorité des
citoyens américains qui est dégoûté qui
veut faire évoluer cette société
dans un sens plus inclusif et et qui
soit une sorte de renouveau du mouvement
des droits civiques et je pense que
grâce à cette horreur qu'on ait 30 ans
vivre il va y avoir un mouvement de
pendule inverse et le prochain président
sera en mesure certainement affecter de
façon plus profonde
le progrès de la société merci jacques
schwarz bart musiciens engagés on s'en
rend compte aussi voilà rendez vous ce
soir donc à 20 heures sur la scène de
tropiques atrium pour sonner cas-là 2
merci bonne journée
les en concert à ce soir